everybody yes everybody on Earth has a
Donald Trump impression most of them are
not very
good I won't even do mine here because
it's not it's not good there's certain
Impressions I can do all right now
listen here there's sit but there's
certain like Trump everyone does the
little will now listen here look okay BL
but it's it's not a great impression to
have a really really great impression
you have to pierce to the heart of a
man's character we will see if these
professional comedians can do it let's
get to Trump gave what I think was
probably one of the greatest speeches of
world leader given you know it's got to
be up there with like Churchill
Gettysburg addess is the night the
United States killed the leader of Isis
Trump comes out of the Situation Room at
like midnight in the white house and he
walks down that fcking tunnel like he's
and gives a press conference like he's
giving a postgame NBA just goes Abu
barar alag daddy is dead he died like a
dog and I'm dude
I didn't change one word of that that's
what he opened with and then he did 40
minutes the speeches 40 minutes the
meanest talk you've ever heard in front
of the whole world
Abu we could hear him crying I said Abu
don't cry Abu let me tell you something
Abu cried he cried quite a bit I
wouldn't have
cried Cry Baby Back daddy that's what we
were all
calling that's a great Trump impression
that is so much better than the majority
of trump Impressions he did a good job
good job because because of the pause
you know a very powerful tool on stage
is stillness and Trump uses it and good
performers use it and so it's the it's
that and Trump's trying to formulate
what he's going to
say really really good very perceptive
Biden's not doing good you ever watch
him talk he starts out yelling and then
he Whispers like the most important part
of the speech read what I said9 trillion
relief so far total opposite of Trump
trump starts out calm and then builds to
a violent screaming by the end of hist
so excuse me think of it we have to save
this great country right no I made this
country so great I made it so great and
then now it's not so great not so great
because of the radical left and you know
these people right radical we call them
radical we say
these people these are right to
left they're
rapists they're murderers they're
our kids chopping their off
putting Bud Lights up their ass at the
border that's what they're doing thank
you it no thank you it so sad think of
it there that little toddler
sway I think I've seen that guy before I
don't where have I I think I've come
across that guy before so so Tyler's is
great because the the previous comedian
got the neck up physicality this thing
with the hand and Tyler has it really
from the neck down and he's got that
kind of trump kind of perches out his
chest a little bit and the sway as he
mentioned the voice is not quite as good
but the crescendo the diminuendo the he
he gets the the Dynamics of it really
really
well and the face to a degree too that's
listen that's another hm a whole other
aspect and it's an impression right it's
not the whole Char it's just a little
impression next one there a lot of great
people on both sides of great people
Jamie Fox does an amazing drum I know
Hario he's a great person he couldn't
vote for me at the time now he can vote
for me once she get sh I love snoopd
Double J what's your favorite Death Row
Record Mr Trump all of them all the
Death Row Records don't try to pin me
down I see what he just excuse me fake
news excuse me fake news fake
news
look down for they tried to give me the
virus I beat the virus say they try to
they they tried to get the vir like who
is
they I beat the virus
like
he man Jam Lee Fox is just a great
performer he gets he gets the voice he's
not doing too much of the physicality
there at all but so it's just a vocal
impression but it's almost perfect makes
sense he's a very versatile performer
you know he's a musician he's an actor
he's a comedian he gets it all is also
quite impressive because he's a black
guy because it's easier for white guys
to do white guys and black guys to do
black guys it's just just there's
something you know you kind of grow up
with all the eccentricities of your
culture and your race but Jamie Fox just
transcends all of it and can he's just
wow that's an amazing performance I was
asked to speak at this hotel it turns
out there's some type of banquet going
on you know one second just give me a
second you you piece of ugly fat
orange yeah social media they had to
take it away I was too good in fact go
ahead put it back up put it back up
people say I've got bad makeup Tana
looks like someone painted her face like
a clown that's what we're going to call
her Tana It the clown she looks like him
she looks like she should be in a sewer
bothering
children
[Music]
any interest you're gay hey blame the
dairy industry I would never suck a
guy's but if I did it'd be one of the
best sucks he's ever had a few years ago
women would have the flat butts not you
you've got a very nice one thank you you
know I did I pulled very well with the
blacks how am I pulling with
you not great that was an amazing mess
of mediocre mediocrity not great he the
one thing I don't want to just totally
knock the impression the one thing he's
got is that he can sit like Trump trump
sits on the edge of his seat shoulders
over but the voice was off the mannerism
is not quite there writing very lazy
it's obviously a liberal sketch but not
great not great oh they gave me so much
press John so much press billions they
say frankly billions of dollars can you
believe this billions of Free Press I
said keep it coming we're going to jail
even if he goes to jail he'll make it
cool right we're going to jail right
nobody goes to jail like I do El Chapo
couldn't do it that quick he couldn't do
it that quick Al Capone took him so long
even when on a rider that sad fat
P
great yeah man it's almost like that guy
Tyler is like a professional comedian or
something you know someone should put
him in a movie are we or aren't we
cutting our off well they're going to
indict your favorite President this is a
horrible thing it is a bigger Hox than
Russia Russia Russia nobody's going into
the Biden Corvette looking at all the
documents he still Biden took more
documents than the amount of times he's
fallen over like a dog and the
indictment is taking place in mij Jami
we love mij Jami it is a Rob dis
sanctimonious state it is a hit job by
Rob it's a horrible thing with they're
doing so the the best part of his
impression which we haven't heard from
the others yet is the ah it's the the
scratching of his vocal cords where
Trump it's not always just this guy yeah
it's like some sometimes there's this
just expulsion of sound this ejaculation
phrasing shut up you know it's kind
of you know and there's this tightening
of the vocal cords and so that was good
he picked up on that the other ones had
not of all the presidents I think it's
fair to say Donald Trump would be the
funniest one to see get
shot cuz he'd be in the middle of a
speech
talking just you're
gay the shooter would be coming at be
like sit down get
down what a loser get down sit
down but just the noise he would make
when he got
hit even if he loved Donald Trump it
would be funny as soon as he got hit he
be
[Laughter]
like ah
but the rest of the joke which is my
favorite part that didn't really a lot
of people didn't like it was uh Biden I
think Biden's the first president you
could punch
assassinate you
just you just walk right up to him be
like Mr President the
you Shang Gillis that guyy is great that
was great imagine how how much much
funnier SNL would be had he been on it
two time zero is still zero infinitely
funnier because there would be one funny
guy that's not fair there Canon
Thompson's pretty funny but there'd be
there'd be then two funny guys on SNL
that'd be great okay which was the best
one Tyler was was good he he probably
gets like a runner up no you know what
man maybe it's Tyler I think it's Tyler
followed by jamy Fox it's Tyler gets the
win though maybe it's just cuz I got to
see two clips but he his this is very
good this is very very good runner up
Jamie Fox after that the first
guy so be it Niel
[Music]
obop